Walmart in Georgia
now has a police station
in one of their stores,
inside the store.
If you think crime is, you know,
a concern for people,
when they're putting
a police station
inside of a Walmart.
And we looked into this
and, you know, police,
they have those, you know,
187 means a murder, I think,
and-- and 51-50 is a,
you know, mental patient.
They have all these...
2-2-1-3 is a robbery, I think.
They have all these codes.
So, we looked at some
of the ones that they have
for the police station
in the Walmart.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
Would you like to hear
some of the ones
that-- I thought you would.
Of course.
Um, they have the, uh--
Oh, a 10-74, that's...
-That's...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
Is the, uh, the 41-20...
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-Uh-huh. (LAUGHS)
-Um...
Oh, a 10-11, that's...
-(ALL LAUGH)
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
DONNA BRAZILE: Glad we got him.
Uh, a 10-89, that's...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-(CHUCKLES)
-Yeah.
-BILL MAHER: Uh...
Uh, 14-70...
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
DONNA: Yes, he's a dead man.
Um, an 18-71 is...
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
Uh, 10-67
is an illegally parked home.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
And, uh, a 15-31 is...